here's what would happen if we  vaccinated all animals for covid-19 well  first of all you'd need a lot of  vaccines there are an estimated 100  billion to 1 trillion mammals on the  planet so you'd be looking at a possible  trillion doses okay say we've got the  vaccines we'd start with livestock and  pets but some people could have trouble  offering their beloved animals up for  injection skepticism would still be an  issue to overcome  the next stop would be zoos and animal  sanctuaries once all zoo animals were  vaccinated we'd move on to a more  challenging task immunizing every wild  mammal on the planet  now there might be an easier way to  deliver the protection other than an  injection we could develop an oral  vaccine and we could give it to animals  without needing to capture them the best  thing about this plan is that these  vaccines would be easier to distribute  globally without Refrigeration so